- Hey everyone, it's Mark Wiens.
I am in Angat, in Bulacan,
which is about an hour and a
half away drive from Manilla.
And today I have a very
special video for you today.
Myself along with Ying and Mikah,
and also my good friend Anton,
and a couple of his boys.
We took a day trip from Manilla,
to this city,
and this is a village,
a Gawad Kaling Village.
And Gawad Kaling is a
social entrepreneurship
within the Philippines that is helping
the poorest of the poor in the Philippines
and not only, providing for them,
but also finding a sustainable
way for many people
to live and to be,
to grow and to create businesses.
We're gonna have lunch here.
We're gonna meet some people
and just walk around,
and so I'm happy to visit
and also to share this video with you.
(upbeat music)
- We have 50 families that
reside in this community.
- [Mark] Alright.
- The community actually started
the fourth year before the corn.
The community was built in 2008.
Is there are over 3000
communities all over
the Philippines.
- [Mark] Okay.
- Within that, this is the first farm.
Malaya.
She's one in biggest
- Hi.
Welcome to the community.
Community.
I'm Malaya.
- Baby.
- I'm baby Malaya.
- Baby Malaya, nice to meet you,
baby Malaya.
- Welcome.
- Thank you.
- Baby Mikah is asleep.
So part of the aspect of the
whole enchanted farm
is the local,
the locals who live within the farm.
- Absolutely.
- So it's all self sustainable.
People live here,
people work here,
and develop creative ideas.
- So the biggest goal
is to eradicate poverty
for five billion families by 2024.
And the first step,
In doing that
is to provide them with housing right.
But then these communities
just give them a sense
of safety and security, right.
And now that do have solid
rooftops over their head,
they can actually switch
from survival mode
to thriving mode.
And the idea now,
is, yeah exactly,
to try to provide them with
opportunities on the farm.
And now they can think about, you know,
earning a sustainable income,
saving money on the side,
and actually having plans for the future,
for their kids, right.
Just be more hopeful and optimistic about
what's coming next.
(upbeat tranquil music)
We have two of our Tita's
here in the community.
This is Tita's friend now.
- Hello.
- And Tita Sellion.
- [Mark] Nice to meet you.
- Hello.
- Good morning!
Not good morning, good afternoon.
- Hi good morning,
well it's still morning,
we're good yeah.
It's a long morning, but yeah.
- [Mark] Oh I can immediately
smell some delicious food.
Whoa!
- I have to put leek, you know?
- [Mark] Beautiful.
- This green onion.
Spring onion.
I will put that,
just like for the toppings.
- This is chicken curry.
- [Mark] Chicken curry, okay.
(foreign language)
- [Mark] This is carrot rice.
- [Woman] Yeah.
- Okay.
- [Woman] I hope you like it.
- [Mark] It looks beautiful.
I already like it.
- Because the chefs are beautiful,
that's right.
- [Mark] Yeah the chefs
are beautiful, yes!
(laughing)
Is curried rice a common Filipino food,
or you?
- I just experiment.
I just started experimenting.
This is healthy,
and it is a balanced diet,
because it is a,
very they say, go, grow and glow.
So it comes only in my mind.
So the goal for this,
is sticky rice,
and then the grow for this is the eggs
and the coconut milk,
and then the glow for this, is the carrot.
That makes our
- It'll make your
skin glows.
- That makes our skin glow.
(laughing)
- Oh yes.
The aroma's coming out of this kitchen
are amazing.
I'm like,
I'm in a,
I'm in like a cloud of
carrot rice right now,
and I'm loving it.
Thank you so much for
allowing us in the kitchen.
Oh.
What are you making here?
- It's a coconut,
veggies.
- [Mark] Okay, vegetables with coconut.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(meat sizzling)
- [Mark] Okay, are cooking one vegetable
and mixed vegetable dish with some squash,
some wong beans and eggplant in there
and then she mixed it with,
coconut milk as well.
And then also frying over here in this pan
is that mongoose,
the milk fish that was marinating as well.
Oh it smells so good.
My mouth is watering,
for lunch.
Can you say that one more time?
- OHGK.
- [Mark] It's called,
the drink is called OHGK.
And it's a combination of
- Oregano, honey, ginger, and kalamansi.
- [Mark] Wow.
Okay, and you are the one
who created this drink?
- Yes I actually have two partners.
Johnson and Angie.
So, both my classmates.
- [Mark] Okay and are you bottling,
it's being bottled now right?
- Yes, yes.
- [Mark] And sold?
- Yes.
Are being sold here in the farm
and trying to, sell to Manilla.
- [Mark] Thank you very much.
- It will be soon.
- [Mark] I can't wait to try it.
I got a cup of the OHGK now.
Oh wow.
Oh that's wonderful.
What really comes in nicely is the ginger,
that you can,
and then it's just perfectly soured.
That's extremely refreshing.
Oh the ginger taste is wonderful.
And the sweetness is coming from honey.
Okay.
Honey which is also from, the farm also?
- Here and the surrounding
communities as well.
The next town, you'll see.
- Okay so they produce honey around here.
(baby talk)
(upbeat music)
- [Man] Would you like some more of the
vegetables as well?
- [Mark] Mikah look at all this food man.
But you can smell it all Mikah.
That food looks amazing.
Home cooked food.
Got the rice, got the vegetables.
How is it Anton?
- This is the best,
when it's a home cooked meal.
- [Mark] Yeah.
It looks so good.
I'm gonna start with those vegetables
and some of that carrot rice.
Oh I cannot wait for this first bite.
Oh yeah.
The rice is nice and gooey.
Like glutinous.
And then the vegetables are,
kinda creamy with that coconut milk,
but nice and soft.
I got a piece oqeur in that bite.
It's awesomely good.
- The vegetables are really good,
by itself.
- [Mark] All the vegetables
are from this farm yeah.
I really wanna taste this Mongoose,
which has been marinated,
she said is some calamansi,
and also some soy and I
think ginger and garlic.
Oh yes.
Mongoose is,
one of the best things to
eat in the Phillippines,
and with some chili and this.
Break this chili.
Oh yeah.
With some of the rice.
Oh I love it.
Oh mongoose is,
such a good fish.
It's so pure.
It is,
kind of has that dryish texture
similar to tuna.
And also the chicken curry looks amazing
with carrots and potatoes.
Wow.
Mm.
Yeah, the curry is really good as well.
- [Man] But not as spicy
as what we're used to.
- But it's very fragrant though.
- But you have to eat the labuyo.
The labuyo,
you have to eat the labuyo.
- What's the labuyo?
- That one.
- This one?
- It's a Filipino chili.
- I will chase it with
with labuyo, okay.
- Yeah.
- [Man] He ate the whole thing?
- Delicious.
(laughing)
- Her doctors.
- And all of a sudden as we're enjoying
this beautiful lunch,
it just started down pouring outside.
It was kind of humid this morning,
so I think the rain was coming.
Oh but that's so refreshing.
I love eating outdoors,
especially when it's raining.
It's wonderful.
(rain drowning out Anton)
- The vegetables.
Everything's good,
but the vegetables' amazing.
(upbeat music)
That was an amazing lunch.
Great delicious food,
and especially the
the generosity of the family was,
amazing.
It's still drizzling a little bit,
but we are walking around the farm
and seeing some of the social
entrepreneurship projects.
(tranquil upbeat music)
One of the things that
they really emphasize
at the GK villages
throughout the Philippines
is that the Philippines
is such a rich country
with full of natural resources.
And, they also really,
make efficient use of the land,
and so, at the GK village right now,
we're walking around some
of the permaculture areas,
and I just wanna read you this sign here
where it says permaculture.
Means permanent agriculture
on an agricultural system
or method that seeks to
integrate human activity
with natural surroundings, so as to
create highly efficient
self sustaining ecosystems.
And so,
you can see on this map which is actually,
this land right here, behind this sign,
they're gonna be producing,
there's gonna be a pond with tilapia,
bananas, gabi and
then around they're gonna
have herbs like oregano,
kang kong, which is water spinach.
So it's a whole, it's an entire ecosystem
that really makes
efficient use of the land.
And then along with people that are living
in this community and working on the farm
and growing the,
and taking care of the agriculture
and the permaculture,
there's also students that
attend the school here
to learn about social entrepreneurship.
So it's a whole,
not only a.
Hello.
- Hello.
- Hi.
An entire ecosystem
that is self sustaining
and that is also profitable
through the projects
that they are doing.
(cat meowing)
(tranquil upbeat music)
(rooster cawing)
Whoa.
Hey guy.
You can probably guess pretty easily,
but this is part of the
chicken raising facility.
(rooster cawing)
Oh hello.
Whoa that's a huge chicken.
Oh the chicken farm,
the chicken range.
Here we go, here's the sign.
Check out the size of
that rooster in there.
You're a huge guy man.
(rooster cawing)
Look at that rooster comb.
- I think we have about
a thousand chickens.
We started one and a half years ago,
where we only had around three hens
that were able to you know do.
- [Mark] Now how many
chickens do you have?
- About a thousand chickens.
- [Mark] About a thousand.
- The thing here is that,
I also came from bombi,
and three years ago I didn't know
how to speak any English.
- Thank you so much for showing us around.
- There's not a lot of
social enterprises were open.
- No, it was really
for me
and I think for anyone visiting,
I think the whole project,
but also hearing the individual stories,
that really is touching,
and is what really
empowering people that have
come from some of the
most impoverished families
in the Philippines and then giving them
a chance here to do something,
and to, really be
to really use their skills.
- Yeah of course.
I mean our goal,
obviously it's one of these big hairy
outrageous goals to eradicate poverty
for five million families.
But again, obviously we
will never do it on our own,
and we're quite aware of that.
But the whole idea is to try to,
inspire everyone right.
Be part of the spacial building movement.
And that's exactly what it is.
- It was really an amazing
opportunity to visit.
Probably lunch was my absolute favorite.
And, all of that home cooking,
a big thank you to all of the Tita's.
But then also learning
about the different stories
of the individuals that go to school
at the GK village,
and then also seeing the permaculture
and the farm,
was,
it's really fascinating.
I wanna say a big thank you to Anton.
- Alright, hello.
- Great trip.
And also thank you to the whole team
at GK and
all of the Tita's and Tito's that we met.
Thank you very much for
watching this video,
please remember to give it a thumbs up
if you enjoyed it.
And, also I'd love to hear from you
in the comments sections below.
And also, if you're
not already subscribed,
click subscribe now for lots more food
and travel videos.
And, goodbye from all of us.
(children screaming)
Bye bye, thank you for watching.